we are just dripping with so much
melanin right now it's so much magic I
mean being in this room just feels
electrifying right now it does you know
this is my favorite event and that's
saying a lot because I go to a lot of
work but I love all this girl power and
all this energy and how everybody's sold
there is such camaraderie in here like
everybody is rooting for everybody and
it's just positive energy no negativity
it's amazing you know one thing we love
is how much your daughter is celebrated
making Marco her and jay-z when they
accept at the Brit Award
did she ever call you before she makes
the decision so call on her mom no she
told me about it showed it to me when
they first did it she told me about the
idea and I thought it was amazing it's
really nice and your other daughter is
hosting tonight Kelly oh my guess you
just celebrated 38 I mean how just
seeing them grow up and just become the
ladies that they become how rewarding is
that for you it's the most rewarding and
you know all that they've achieved the
best thing about them is how good and
grounded they are we just left a two
hour chat group chat with Solange and
Kelly and Beyonce and Angie and myself
and I thought about that and I was like
you know we've just been having so much
fun for two hours and they're just
regular good people you love that and
and you're a really huge part of that
keeping them grounded Tina Knowles
Lawson told ET when she's not texting
her girls she's watching her bonus
daughters hit show it's been such a
pleasure having my kids it's the best
job I've ever had
and they are you know they they are
affecting the world and the creativity
of the world and I couldn't be more
proud of that not only my kids what my
husband's daughter Bianca
is killing it on Queen sugar and I mean
this it's like a dream you know that
they all get to do what they love and
get paid for it which is missioning
Bianca that she ever spill in the
Queen's sugar tea - you know I don't I
don't put on the spot I want to because
I'm a huge fan of the show but I'll let
her slide
[Music]